un vieux rêve devenu réalité depuis 3
mois mathilde balouir a ouvert son
entreprise d'insertion dans les métiers
de la restauration son nom utopique 78
un projet de longue date qui a mis 10
ans à voir le jour j'ai toujours eu
l'esprit
d'entreprendre je je voulais vraiment
créer une entreprise à mon image en fait
voilà donc avec l'insertion
professionnelle au cœur de notre métier
et aussi autour de la restauration pour
offrir du plaisir aux personnes une
démarche solidaire fondamentale car
l'ambition première du topic 78 c'est
d'accompagner et de former des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi l'objectif c'est
de lever tous les freins à l'emploi
aujourd'hui on a deux personnes en
insertion et un encadrant technique chef
de cuisine qui les accompagne ils ont un
parcours de 2 ans maximum au sein de du
toopicque 78 pour accéder à l'emploi
durable nous on va les accompagner déjà
sur la remise à l'emploi sur
l'acquisition de compétences techniques
par la formation qui va être délivrée
par l'encadre technique mais également
par des formation qu'on va pouvoir leur
financer par ailleurs un défi de taille
pour cette ancienne directrice d'agence
d'intérim qui ne connaissait rien à la
vie d'entrepreneur il fallait que je me
crée les compétences que je n'avais pas
en gestion d'entreprise en management
pour la construction de mon business
plan j'ai été accompagné par BGE au ski
cube ensuite pour le financement j'ai
également été accompagné par deux
structures qui sont initiative 5qu1 qui
est présente au ski cube aussi et France
Active également je suis accompagnée
aussi dans le cadre de mon lancement de
projet autour de l'esss par émergence et
labo trempelin donc en fait tous les
freins que j'avais et les difficultés
ils sont levés grâce à l'accompagnement
des structures qui sont présentes sur le
territoire ces structures n'ont pas
seulement aidé mathil Ballouard àqu érir
des compétences elles ont également levé
des freins qui empêchaient la jeune
femme d'atteindre ses rêves les
difficultés en tant que femme je me les
mets moi-même c'est-à-dire que je vais
plutôt penser que je suis moins bonne ou
moins performante que que d'autres mais
c'est pareil enfin j'ai beaucoup de
bienveillance autour de moi de tous les
partenaires que je rencontre pour la
suite Mathilde balouir voit grand elle
souhaiterait agrandir sa brigade en
insertion et pourquoi pas développer son
activité sur d'autres sites